[Music]
hi there very Demi you're watching the
Press preview of first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive tonight
it's time to see what's making the
headlines and tonight we're joined by
the director of the John Smith Institute
at the University of Glasgow Kezia
dugdale also the Barrister and former
government Minister Anna subi welcome to
you both thank you so much for standing
by tonight they're going to be with us
now until just before midnight this
evening let's start by seeing what's on
some of those front pages as we get them
hot off the press here at Sky News
starting with the guardian leading on
Britain becoming the first Western
Country to provide Ukraine with
long-range Storm Shadow cruise missiles
the front of the eye says the chancellor
has admitted a key inflation Target
might not be reached with treasury
sources believing inflation will stay
higher for longer on to the Ft the front
page there also leads with the bank of
England's raising of interest rates and
a warning that's inflation Target will
not be reached now until 2025 the front
of the times it says food prices are on
the way back down in the coming months
the governor the bank of England blaming
underlying shock for stubbornly high
inflation the Metro says investigators
of a sheep attack in gloucestershire
have found definitive proof that big
predatory cats are roaming in our
Countryside and on the front of the
Daily Mail prison officers have been
told to stop calling criminals convicts
in case it offends them onto the Sun for
you tomorrow is leading on a story honor
this morning presenter Phillip Schofield
and a reminder also for you that by
scanning the QR code that you're going
to see on screen during the program you
can see it right there you can check out
the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch with us now as I said we
would joining we are joined tonight by
Kezia dugdale and Anna subri good
evening to you both thank you so much
for staying up way past your bedtimes
I'm sure to help us look through the
papers tonight and we're going to start
with let me make sure I've got the right
one the Metro actually inside Pages page
four and of course this is a huge story
something that we've been headlining
here on Sky News all night uh the UK
gift of a cruise missile to Ukraine that
brings a threats Kelsey let's start with
you what do you make of their coverage
of this very big story tomorrow
so this is a really significant
development in with regards to what's
happening in Ukraine we've got the UK
defense sector here Ben Wallace having
made a statement to Parliament saying
that we're going to be the first country
the United Kingdom is going to be the
first country to give Ukraine long-range
missiles missiles storm missiles which
have the ability to um go three times
the distance of any existing missiles
that the Ukrainian forces are using it's
not a risk-free Endeavor though because
it will likely lead to an escalation in
what the Russians use in return and
we're very aware of the fact that the
Russians have a type of missile that can
go far far further than even this
incredibly powerful technology which
we're about to give to the Ukrainian so
Ben Wallace described it in the
parliament today is a calibrated
response a considered response but it
does come with a risk and we could be
moving into new phase here as Ukraine
attempts to go for a counter and action
in response to what's happened over the
past few days
um they actually go on to say there's
been a surge in Ukrainian strikes behind
Russian Lions as Kiev prepares to launch
a long-anticipated
counter-offensive however the president
of Vladimir zielinski is saying it'll
need more time as it waits the delivery
of military aid I mean Anna where do you
stand on this story do you back what Ben
Morris is doing
yes absolutely and there's no debate
about it
um we cannot allow this illegal invasion
of Ukraine to continue and we must do
everything that we can to assist the
Ukrainian people in their determination
to rid their land of these aggressive
Invaders
um if you listen to what the ukrainians
have said almost from the beginning is
they obviously have the most
extraordinary determination they've been
very successful since the invasion I
mean it you know everybody thought that
once this terrible thing had happened it
wouldn't be long before Moscow would
achieve what it wanted to achieve and we
could imagine Ukraine falling in fact
it's been the absolute opposite yes the
Russians have taken land but my goodness
me the ukrainians have fought back and
indeed they've regained land which they
lost at the beginning
but the thing that they've always said
is yes we have the determination yes we
have the ability and we have the people
but what they lack is the kit and they
need precisely this sort of Weaponry in
order to do the job which they seek to
do which is to keep their country well
they've lost the large part of their
country because they've been invaded But
to to regain their country and to see
off Putin uh and his other war criminals
who've invaded their country so
disgraceful well this story is on the on
the front of other newspapers as you
would expect including the guardian that
we had a brief look at that front page a
minute ago let's have a look in a bit
more detail uh there are three stories
on the front page but of course this is
that this is the above above the middle
line if you like the UK sends long-range
missiles to Ukraine and first for West
that's the headline there and Kezia the
guardian giving us a bit more detail
saying that Ben Wallace didn't say how
many Storm Shadow missiles will be given
to Ukraine but saying that they they
estimate the UK holds a stock of between
700 and a thousand of these missiles
yes and each of these missiles costs 2
million pounds so this is a really
significant financial investment in the
war Ukraine as well what I think is so
interesting about it though is that
there's a suggestion from Ben Wallace
that there might already be missiles
within Ukraine who wouldn't comment or
be drawn too far on how many were being
sent and when they would arrive and when
they might be first be used the second
foot to the studio is interesting in the
guardian is it extrapolates a bit more
as to why now Anna's right to say
Ukraine have been calling for these
missiles for months and months the
answer to the question why now is really
what's happened over the past couple of
days is a significant increase in
Russia's attacks on civilian
infrastructure the guardian reporting
was now nearly 800 accounted for
incidences of the Russians attacking
non-military assets we saw that in the
past few days with the real sort of
Kamikaze style set of drone attacks in
cave and I think that's led to the
United Kingdom to go that this this
can't go on like this there are many
thousands of civilians now dying
unnecessarily there needs to be a step
up remember it's not one without risk
and the Brits have assured or asked
Ukraine for some significant reassurance
here that these missiles which were
given to the Ukrainian forces will be
used within Ukrainian territory so they
must not be used or on Russian soil
because if that were to happen that
would really escalate matters in a way
that I think would make many countries
across the globe deeply deeply
uncomfortable and I know you're not
making agreement there because it makes
a really good point there about the risk
that's something also that the Guardians
article raises at the end saying there
have been concerns that these missiles
could be used to strike targets deep
inside Russia's internationally
recognized territories of course that
would create a whole different situation
wouldn't it I mean is that a concern
that you share
no because I I think that the we can
trust the ukrainians they know that they
have to use these missiles to attack the
Russians in their invasion in Ukraine
and they must not go into Russian
territory so they know that and the
ukrainians aren't stupid they know that
if that would be a serious breach and
Not only would it incur the rough
obviously of the rest of the world that
it would also mean that in the future
there would be a there would be
restrictions obviously there'd be
debated no doubt those restrictions
about further Supply are Weaponry if
they breach those rules so yeah I think
the biggest the biggest problem the
concern is going to be what the Russians
do about this and how they then escalate
things but you know as kids here says we
I think in all of this because it's been
going on for so long I mean we all know
how important it is but it does fall off
the the the top of the stories even the
front pages and you know the the one of
the many outrages is the fact that you
know Russia was blatantly attacking and
killing civilians I mean it really is
quite shocking it is disgraceful uh and
we're doing the right thing by standing
with zelenski and his people uh and and
giving them that the arms that they
desperately need okay let's let's take a
chance to have a look at some other
papers now and some other Indie some
other stories which are leading those
papers let's start with the financial
times again a huge story today of course
interest rates Rising with Bank of
England and maybe uncultural reading for
Andrew Bailey on the front page of the
Ft tomorrow b of e lifts rates and warns
inflation Target will not be reached
until 2025 the cost of borrowing hits a
15-year High threat to synac Pledge on
prices and mortgage pain deepens it's a
painful read to say the least there's an
Anna let's stick with you on this one
yeah it is look that this is obviously
for people who are uh paying their
mortgages and now see an increase in
interest rates in already difficult
times because the cost of living crisis
this causes them yet more concern puts
more pressure notably on families then
you have the bank of England's warnings
which are the inflation is not going to
harvest the government has said it's
made these I think it's five pledges of
things that Rishi soon act says he's
going to do by the time that the next
election is called which must be about
the end of next year and so one of those
is this absolute aim that they're going
to reduce inflation and what the bank of
England is saying is that they're not on
course to do that and of course it's a
huge point for labor because I think one
of their big messages if you like or
asks of the British people is going to
be after 13 years of conservative
government are you actually better off
or worse off at the end of that tenure
is it well coming into that general
election and I think overwhelmingly
people are going to say we're worse off
on all sorts of levels but notably this
is bad news for the government if it
seeks to achieve its Target
yeah let's bring you in on that because
I'm sure you've got something to say
about it because the Ft saying that the
bank of England predicting that invasion
is not going to fall as fast and
actually sunak might miss his pledge to
halve inflation by the end of the year
yes I mean Anna's absolutely correct the
single biggest most politically potent
question in any uh general election
contest is when people ask themselves
are they better or worse off under the
government of the day so this will send
shudders down the spine of those people
in Downing Street uh don't think that
inflation is the biggest story in this
story although of course it's the one
we're focused on because it's linked to
the promise that prime minister Rishi
sunak made to have inflation over the
Year this point about interest rates
going I'm up today is when we're all
familiar with and we know how
significant that is to mortgage payers
and and Anna's just detailed why the
bank of England have also predicted that
interest rates will continue to rise to
five percent by the end of this year
that means the pain is going to continue
the other thing to note in the story is
it also predicts that growth across the
United Kingdom is going to remain around
the one percent Mark for the next three
years that's going to seriously affect
the government's ability to generate
additional Revenue to spend on public
services there's some really big bad
news in the in the detail of this story
I suppose the question is what's the
alternative when you're both in
agreement here but but what else could
we Rishi sinach and the Tory government
have done Anna to you first
well it it to me it's rather obvious I
mean we know that by our decision to
leave the European Union are
um National
um income if you like our prosperity has
been hit and reduced by four percent so
one of the the easiest quickest hits
that you could have is to have a better
alignment with our European neighbors to
make sure that we trade much more
effectively and efficiently with them
and so you could have that debate about
whether we join the Customs Union
whether we look at the single Market but
certainly better alignment with the
European Union would immediately improve
our economic prospects that would have a
real boost for our economy so there's
one of the first things that we could do
but there will be other things and and
tackling productivity tackling growth is
is critically important and it's tough
it's difficult there aren't easy silver
bullets but you know investment in
infrastructure I would argue is one of
the ways that we can improve certainly
our growth prospects and as we look at
the front page of the I knew UK
inflation warning as hunt admits key
pledge may be broken just in 40 seconds
if you don't mind Kezia what do you
think the labor party should have done
or should have done if they were in
power
well they wouldn't cut spending that's
that's the reality and the UK
government's forced to do that because
of less trust's failures but you can't
um address productivity or drive
investment without putting some serious
government-led cash in that would be the
difference I think